everyone stop everything you're doing
because we are coming to Europe on tour
trash taste Europe tour 2023 is
happening we hinted it in a previous
episode but now it is official we are
selling tickets right now click the link
down in the description below Joey where
are we going I'm glad you asked let me
tell you right now August 30th Dublin
Ireland September the 2nd Copenhagen
Denmark September 4th Amsterdam
Netherlands which is already sold out so
thank you very much guys September the
5th Stockholm Sweden September 6th Oslo
Norway September 7th Berlin Germany
September 9th London UK and September
the 11th Cardiff Wales we are going to
all of those locations right now tickets
are available but they're going fast
click the links down in the description
below do it I'll see you there a lot of
people look at shirabaka as being like
this is a documentary a lot of the
Israel when we're driving to pick up
animators we see other Studio rival
Studios just stare at each other like
this and they start revving in there
everyone welcome back to another episode
of the trash test podcast I'm your host
for today Joey and as always I am with
the boys and uh Rejoice anime fans
because this is an anime episode because
oh yeah because of the gentleman sitting
next to me introduce yourself hi I'm
yoshihiro Watanabe I am one the producer
for Trigon Stampede hell yeah yeah it's
so hype it's been a while since we had
uh like an anime industry kind of guest
Stone yeah I think the last one was like
Kevin penkin right yeah he's amazing
yeah so we've had a animatron we've had
a composer on and now we have like an
anime producer on as well I hope I'm not
missing anyone have I missed have I
missed any other Industries no I think
that's about it yeah anime voice actor
voice actor we're like Thanos collecting
yeah collecting all the industries the
the reason why you might be wondering
trash days why did it take so long for
you guys to finally get a producer on
the show well it's because uh a lot of
them don't speak English yes yes you
know it's kind of an English show but uh
luckily
I was born in Tokyo but I grew up in L.A
okay okay okay and uh you you know you
mentioned that you uh produced the new
China Dragon stampy but you've done a
lot more than that uh you're also the
producer for B Stars right yes so high
so how many shows have you worked on
just just like lay out your resume like
spit yeah listen listen down listen down
I'm genuinely here I mean as a producer
I um well I work for a studio Orange
um it's a cg-based company but from
there it's my producer career started
sort of right so B stars
um I worked on the Godzilla single point
ah okay Stampede I worked on some shorts
um before orange I worked on um some
League of Legends commercials oh oh
really yeah let's go
yeah yeah with like the the really like
intense 3D animated ones yeah oh there's
one's a really great the hand-drawn
animated ones oh okay okay so those are
so sick honestly stopped doing that yeah
before okay and that was like one of the
best parts of the Legends I think it's
really fun working on it yeah yeah [__]
yeah yeah
um so how long have you been in the
industry industry um that's in 2006 when
I graduated from college ever since then
yeah oh damn so actually started from
like uh us studio
um of U.S branch of madhouse okay oh
they're working with uh Hollywood to
adapt into live action at the time I
didn't even know there was a U.S
pressure yeah I'm learning that now as
well wow so okay so like I've always
been curious right you know even as
someone who uh you know talks about a
lot of anime uh I've never truly
understood what exactly the role of an
anime producer is so especially for our
audience do you want to explain what an
anime producer does okay so it gets
really extensive so I'm gonna make it
simple it's anime producer is if you
don't have anyone you're the only one to
do everything yeah
it's kind of what I figured because it's
like that it would like you know the
producers the kind of the guy who just
ends up having to do fill in all the
gaps yeah yeah the director obviously
has his role in the actors of theirs and
produces like kind of everything in
between you've got to fall under this
thing okay so if I don't have a
production assistant I'm the one who's
cleaning after everyone else's food
truck food trash Oh okay wow okay sorry
but yeah everything my part of the job
is finding the budget to hire people to
do that so right basically a pretty new
team yeah I'm not finding the budget yes
what is that was that that sounds like
ominous
yeah I mean every two people to work
right right right right so like you work
with you know Studio Orange right now
which you know I I would say I think
it's like the Premier Studio for 3D like
3D animation I mean you uh City Orange
has made shows like you know B Stars
Trigon hose
I believe as well and I feel like Studio
orange is like leading the charge so so
like make sure that 3D animation gets a
good rep yeah especially from anime
definitely
um how much exposure do you get from the
fan base in terms of their
preconceptions with 3D anime I know um I
mean it's a really great honor that a
lot of fans consider this that yeah um
from our perspective we actually feel a
little bit more different we're just
using it as a tool right to because all
our CEOs animator right and he wants to
just fully Express
um whatever he wants to do so he's just
we're just using that as a tool okay
okay there wasn't was there ever like a
conscious choice of like this is why
we're using 3D or was it just kind of
like it just kind of made sense so today
um as the studio was found about one
animator yeah he was working for a jump
on among artists as an assistant back
then he found Pixar he found truck Toy
Story and he's finally got this what he
called Claire Clarity that yeah
animation from there right right oh
that's interesting because I know like a
lot of well a lot of Japanese anime in
the animation industry is based around
2D anime so I think it's cool that you
know there's a lot there's been a lot of
experimentation done with 3D animation
in the past industry and I feel like
Studio orange just ends up doing things
a little bit differently yeah you guys
kind of just like figured it out I guess
it's like the best way to put it like
because you know this there's been like
even if you go back to like early 2000s
right there were not full 3D anime but
you know definitely like a lot of 3D
artists working on like backgrounds or
like you know action sequences and stuff
like that but there were so many shows
in my opinion whereas just it was very
obvious yeah that there was this is 3D
and then everything else is in 2D right
but there's something about the worker
Studio orange where it almost blurs that
line yeah to the point where sometimes
I'm watching it and I almost forget that
it's actually 3D yeah if that makes
sense so it's like do you do you think
there's like some kind of a what's
what's your secret yeah what's the
secret
like what what makes Judy orange just
like stand out so much in the field of
streaming actually to any business
partner what I explained is that we're
actually the hentai of anime Industries
so hentai
[Applause]
yeah okay so we're the psychopath where
The Maniacs yeah right so like what
which okay let's there's so much I want
to ask but in terms of like can you like
elaborate on that what do you do
differently uh in terms of like everyone
else right now in the industry in your
minds that makes CD orange work stand
out uh I mean nowadays um there's so
many actually CD Studios actually
starting to rise right I mean Dragon
Ball super amazing yeah um Sam slam dunk
that's blew my mind yeah yeah I haven't
seen that have you seen that yeah I I
saw bits and pieces of it but I haven't
actually seen the full movie it walks
yeah I've only heard amazing things
about it okay because yeah every time I
see like 3D like anime I'm not gonna lie
part of my brain is like oh no
wow I had that exact same reaction when
I saw that b Stars was getting an anime
yeah right because like compared to the
manga which is like itagi Potter's style
is very sketchy and like very rough like
clearly just like you know Rough Around
the Edges but in the best way possible
and then when I heard that oh B stars is
getting anime and as a monger fan I was
like this is great I [__] love these
stars and then the moment I saw the
trailer I was like there was a part of
me that was like oh no
it's in 3D but then when I saw the
studio orange name I was like okay yeah
you know what there's a chance that'll
be good and thankfully [__] amazing
thank you yeah absolutely incredible I
think it is me that um we literally
focus on the what is the essence of that
right so B Stars the drawing is really
fantastic but there's to recreate that
and CG it's possible but it's easy
there's a lot of um tools that you need
so it's gonna cost a lot of money to
recreate that yeah so what is the
essence what can we pick out to the
essence whatever that's possible within
that realm right now to adapt it I think
that's really really great at I'm
curious do you think in your opinion is
3D animation harder than 2D animation or
is it just that they have different
strengths rather than one being harder
than the other they definitely have
different strengths from hand drawing I
mean if you have a pencil and paper you
just start yeah with whatever skill you
have and Imagination yeah 3D you have to
have a tool so it's all based on
formulas and numbers and stuff right
because I feel like a lot of the
preconception especially with a lot of
you know people who watch anime is that
you know we've seen I guess the
evolution of the use of 3D and Anime and
a lot of the times they always felt like
3D was used maybe it's as like a tool
that meant you know you had to put less
work in uh rather than costs and to cut
production time and stuff like that but
I think one thing that really said to
you orange apart is that instead of
using it as like kind of like a cost
cutting thing you kind of like use the
tool to its fullest potential which we
see with of a lot of your work and I was
wondering did that philosophy like come
right at the get-go or was it just you
know your CEO being like I want to do 3D
this is the way forward I mean it's
sorry about that I'm undo 3D
um so his professional work I don't know
a lot of people who watches this um but
there's a show called zoids oh
[Music]
was equivalent to a reboot oh yeah yeah
what so what like I'm curious what is
your opinion of the evolution of like
the use of 3D in anime from like the
past like decade or so
because we've we see it quite a lot more
often now um
of evolution that's a hard question yeah
um I think really what Japan needed was
the budget time to really grow right I
mean Hollywood had twice or not twice I
mean digits different a budget yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and everything was English so CG
software was all primarily English right
right oh yeah Japan needed to adapt to
that so we're starting off later than
the English first before you can even
start modeling right yeah yeah I mean
our CEO bought this um 30k software back
then right and then the manual is all
English so he's like doing dictionary oh
[__] oh my God okay yeah that'll take a
while yeah because I remember like
growing back uh going back to like
growing up in anime in like the
mid-2000s I remember like was it like
Studio Gonzo or something that used a
lot of 3D also go hands as well go hands
as well yeah Gonzo did like dance yep
they did uh Duo as well and they had
like the 3D back then was let's say very
different from what it like what it
looks like now and just seeing the
progression of 3D people were still
always complain about 3D but I feel like
now is getting to the point where it's
becoming a lot less noticeable yeah
which is I think is a which I think is
the big thing would you say a lot of
that is just the industry kind of like
learning the software properly and
seeing how it's like how knowing how to
use it properly yeah I think uh over
overall throughout the entire industry
it's starting to reach that point the
breaking point right everything is
starting to evolve right what what do
you think is like the secrets like
to making something that to integrating
3D into anime because I feel like Studio
orange do the best so yeah like again it
was that like as I was saying with B
Stars it's like it's almost it's you
know it's 3D but there's a feeling and I
don't know if it's like the movement or
the the coloring the shading whatever it
might be that just makes it makes you
forget it's 3D and I think that's the
best 3D in anime where it's like it
doesn't it there isn't this like weird
there's a thought in the back of your
head of I'm watching a 3D anime yeah I'm
just watching a good anime right 60 FPS
in it 60 60fps anime who would have
thought
I'd better get it yeah right
I'm curious how did you because you
mentioned the the mad house thing but
how did you even get started in in oh
yeah because I you know we're coming out
here with my 3D but I don't even like
know like anything about I guess your
background will happen yeah how do you
get started in the anime industry to the
point where you can rise to and produce
a little actually uh I started in the
weird position so I was just fooling
around in LA and I actually volunteered
for an expo As an interpreter oh wow
seriously okay I met the producer Mario
myself the founder of that house then
he's like my God I was actually supposed
to after college I didn't say that yeah
but he's like we're starting a studio
here you should join us I'm like wait
wait how did that yeah
I feel like I feel like you're glossing
over still a lot of no no one's just
like hey man yeah cool we're not
interpreting you did yeah we get people
we get people at conventions being like
yeah I really want to work for trash
taste we're not just gonna be like well
come on in like you know it's not that
easy right so it's like was it that easy
or was it that easy no no mean he he
mariama has a really Keen Eye on like
looking at people right like he he grew
up his entire career after physical Samu
and that level Mastery creates a lot of
crazy people and yeah I really really
have keen eyes yeah how long did you
live in LA uh I mean I grew up in La so
from six to yeah after college oh down
oh wow okay so he's like hey come work
for me move to Tokyo and you're just
like all right well it was actually the
first to come to the LA office oh right
of course yeah I started working at the
LA office a month later he calls me up
you should move Tokyo I'm like okay um
that sounds really exciting when do I do
this next week I'm like no I'm gonna
give you one week oh my God why was
there like a project that desperately
needed
I'm just gonna [__] with this kid right
now
the real ones will do it this only
happens in Jupiter like this is like a
Japanese mindset of like we have to test
the determination yeah
he's like Yoda but I mean
um
oh oh okay oh that's cool he founded a
studio mapper as well well mapper seems
to just do everything now yeah yeah
seems to be getting getting every FIP
Under the Sun you know okay okay well
damn that's him okay so what job were
you doing at mad house so I started out
as assistant producer for the live
action part of the process right right
so then um there was a project that
we're working with Japan the wachowskis
um were actually producers at the time
Matrix yeah wow so they're doing want to
show with Matt house so that's what
about it damn okay I didn't know this
we're not talking about animatrix right
no no no something else after that yeah
comic they do they produce called
Shaolin Cowboy okay and by Jeff Darrow
and that they want to adapted that into
anime oh wow then I flew over to Japan
so did I ever get released no yeah I was
like how many how many projects end up
getting canceled then because that's
that's obviously like one what's what's
the ratio to yeah I mean there wasn't in
anime industry there's not too many
projects that can't get canceled well
after it launches right okay but yeah
mine was a rare case right it was an
international production Hollywood's
involved and a lot of movies
uneasy at the times right right right I
I'm curious so you said you just turned
up in Japan did he tell you what you
were gonna do a week later in Japan or
was it just like we'll figure it out
he wanted me to be the line producer for
this show I'm like how am I going to be
in line for this without any kind of
experience what is my producer of
curiosity so line producer if you manage
entire production uh under a producer to
so basically you'll the producer yeah
Jesus Christ producer tells you what to
do and then you go actually you do it
man this the other guy sounds he's got
the way better jokes and then I mean he
says that but it's not that well he
needs it so I saw every industry guest
we've had on this like the weirdest yeah
Journey because uh you're talking about
it so nonchalantly yeah that's why I'm
confused so you get here and he's like
be a line producer are you like sure or
is it kind of like oh okay I mean okay I
have no [__] clue
yes yeah yes
I mean I'm giving you a chance you have
to say yes obviously I know that but
you're like all right okay and then I
guess I assume that they must have been
happy with your work because they kept
giving you work no so actually oh God I
don't know like here at math house was a
wreck because I actually didn't know
understand what really what kind of
termination was required to be in
Dynamic production right right so I
actually caught myself as a [__] piece
of [__] back then so
and now look where you are I started
from the bottom now we're here
I mean all the teams the friends that
made back then um that's actually now at
Orange so my fellow producer is
originally from math house two of them
so what's the what's the timeline
looking like so you you moved to Japan
how long is it then from being involved
with this show being a line producer to
then kind of getting the opportunity to
work with Studio orange like what's that
timeline so I graduated college 2006. um
I went into math Houston so 2012 I left
madhouse right I actually kind of got
depressed with the state of the industry
and yeah I kind of left the industry
yeah and went into Venture company
X-Men's two Venture companies and it was
two of them exploded so oh geez I'm
trying to have these crappy businesses
I'm gonna go adventure camp
and then you went from Venture Capital
back into anime yes I guess um uh
someone who I knew at PA works right
um was very kind enough to say that um
my perspective is very interesting so
why don't you work for us so I spent a
couple days a couple years there and
then went to Orange okay PA Works what
have what that's a studio uh they've
produced um
yeah
[Music]
I don't know the studios doesn't mean
anything to me I'm like I'm more like
boneless I don't know
so I'm curious what uh what anime did
you grow up with what uh what are some
of your favorite anime that I guess yeah
what was the what was the anime that I
guess inspired you to go into that field
right I mean foreign
[Music]
how was it like getting the job to
re-adapt Trigun so I was actually never
expecting to work on Dragon though so it
was actually um I came in later into
project so my friend my partner and
friend producer walkie was the one who's
founded founded the project Right and
started but first when I opened the book
I mean I was like everyone else I'm like
what the [__] are you guys doing
it's like don't touch a classic please
yeah there must have been some kind of
trepidation there where you hear like
you re you're re-adapting it like yeah
it was pretty good yeah kind of like a
bit of like I don't know if this is
gonna work
I mean when I I mean the more
information I knew about the entire
picture
um I was more comfortable with it right
right yeah right I mean as a um as a
first um project that how it started was
that it was the producers went naito the
original creator of Triton himself
saying that we want to make Trigun yeah
but naito was like well
I would love you guys to expand on it
not adapt it again right yeah yeah
actually it's already been adapted yeah
yeah what was like the philosophy when
it came to re-adapting a a show that a
lot of people held dear to their hearts
uh because there must have been a lot of
pressure on you guys to get this right I
mean we're all from I mean even director
himself we have kind of LinkedIn
lineage to try gun oh okay so the um
director's master was the triguns
director oh wow okay okay okay so we we
all of us have very special feelings to
the 98 Trigon yeah it's like I will
overpass you master
look at me yes as the ambition we
definitely had that oh yeah for sure as
a work we're never intention to
re-rewrite everyone's precious memories
yeah but to be work along with it so I
mean it was very different from the
original as well in a lot of aspects I
think yeah I think it was really good it
was very different but I I you know I
feel like it was in a good way
um because I've seen enough remakes that
just try to redo everything like step by
step in like modern animation and I
really appreciated that you guys win a
completely different direction while I
think keeping the core of try again yeah
you kept the vibe for sure anime has had
a bit more success with remakes in
general than uh other mediums uh I mean
like Hunter Hunter and Fullmetal
Alchemist but I mean when you compare it
to like how then recently they announced
that they're remaking Moana in live
action oh yeah you ever you ever think
man I
as a producer or creators are ever
concerned we like is there going to be
too many remakes or are we going to be
making too many of these like I always
just wonder about that when you make
when you're working on a remake you're
like are we this is a good idea I don't
know I don't know yeah I feel I feel
anime doesn't have as much of a problem
that like Hollywood remakes have been
going through especially like Disney
remakes and stuff like that yeah just
because I think we've learned from the
past that you know uh sometimes the
remakes aren't really worth it yeah you
know and and I feel like the most
successful remakes are the ones where at
least in the anime world are the ones
where it took the original Vibe and the
concept and just gave us something
completely different right like the
reason why I like The Fruits Basket
remake was so successful is because it
did exactly that it took kind of an
incomplete story from the anime and just
kind of took all of the parts that were
wrong with it and just improved upon it
without changing the vibe and it ended
up being an amazing remake so I feel
like full matter brother four mental
Brother full metal Brotherhood full
metal
full I've watched full metal yeah
clearly for myself Brothers
yeah I feel like after that just like
there was a whole wave of just like Oh
Santa was like the Remake is so good oh
yeah JoJo's technically a remake yeah I
guess so I guess so yeah okay I I want
to know without obviously spoiling
anything that you're working on now what
goes into the decision making of what
gets a season two and what doesn't get a
season two as an anime producer you
probably have the most uh perspective
about this I mean we get a lot of
request to make season two of course
yeah but I mean first we have to give in
the choice to make season two okay I
mean we have clients yeah so is the
client gonna give us a choice to make
season two right right I mean we I mean
so far if once we're given the choice we
always said yes so far yeah okay but
other projects um we haven't done is
that we don't have the choice to say it
yet right I mean maybe one day it'll
come by but yeah because it's it's
always so weird as an anime viewer you
see some of the things that are on like
their fifth season and then some fan
favorite shows never go past like season
one and I'm like this this makes no
sense to me AKA data live and No Game No
Life
is that just because the framework of
how anime gets made is just so complex
with a lot of parties that get a say and
if it does or doesn't happen is that the
reason why I mean the the business model
is a very
um similar way but the people involved
are all different yeah so it's really
hard to say what's happening I mean it
could be the original Creator it could
be how the business the producers are
what could be the studio or there's a
complete other reasons so so uh the
Anime Studio only gets involved after
everything else has already been
approved or does Studio orange get to
you know be at the sea when shows are
being pitched for like not even like a
season two but just to be made in the
field like do you guys get to like
negotiating like we personally really
want to see a season two of this what do
you think kind of thing
um it depends on project project um
orange because we're CG based we have a
lot of limitations so like shows
involves 100 characters we can't do it
because that means equals a lot of
budget right right the business model
currently doesn't support that kind of
budget so there's no way we can get that
budget so why does increasing the
characters increase the budget so to
make one character it involves making a
CG model yeah which costs a lot of money
so making hundreds of that is equals
times that oh okay and that's why you
end up with the CG crowds where all the
characters just are the same model
because it's a lot cheaper right and
same movement as well yeah exactly but
by that logic when we see some 3D and
Anime uh into the anime surely it would
be more expensive than to produce a
model and then animate that model just
for like one scene in anime or is there
some kind of cost cutting method that
makes more sense for that so in our case
um I can't speak for others yeah yeah
yeah but in Orange case that's why we
use still hand run characters as well so
in V Stars if you notice them there's a
lot of hand-drawn characters yeah yeah
one scene only characters okay that's uh
yeah I mean how much do you put into
like
let's say you let's say you were given a
series right and you still want to like
hand draw some scenes how do you choose
which scenes you want to like hand draw
versus which scenes you want to like
keep completely in 3D it totally depends
on what can we do in 3D right so if the
3D is going to explode into 3000 pieces
um then in that case our bfx team is
very excellent so they could they'll say
they could do it okay but if it's going
to let's say split into 100 characters
right then our animation team says that
we can't do that oh okay okay so how big
is your team in terms of like your let's
say 2D animation kind of like like
specialty we currently have about over
100 employees oh so every year we have
about
um 20 employees trying to extend the
studio right we think that's limit of
how we could train people right okay
okay
um and I guess like you like I guess I'd
like to learn know more about
you know you have your own like journey
into the anime industry but
if say someone's watching this right now
and they were interested into getting
into the anime industry maybe as like a
producer or any other kind of role what
is like now that you've been here for
like 10 10 odd years what's your like
advice to people who actually want to
get into the animation in this room
yeah it totally depends what you want to
do in this industry if you want to be an
animator then just start drawing and
then if you haven't drawn start drawing
just apply to any studio right we have a
lot of short digits in this industry so
I don't say um I can't say I speak for
other Studios so um I can't say for
their working condition
but I mean if I please find the good
working condition partner to work okay
okay this episode is sponsored by boxer
boxer delivers the experience of tasting
authentic Japanese snacks candies and
tea sourced directly from Sentry's old
small family businesses right to your
door their mission is to empower Japan's
traditional snack makers by sharing the
authentic food and stories with the
world thanks to Foxy me and the boys eat
good every single month every month they
send us a new box and this month's theme
is birthday best happy birthday boxer
and to celebrate boxu's birthday in this
boxu you will get the best of the
classics the favorites from the fans of
boxu all in one great box stop talking
I've already seen this I've eat this
every time it's in a box suit it's the
white strawberries baby I love these
what are you going for Jerry what do you
got there well I've got the tea pairing
that they have and this one is Sakura
matcha latte hell yeah hold on I pick
one pick one all right I mean they're
all great obviously I shouldn't I have
the Yuzu pepper sembe
that already looks beautiful oh that
looks so tasty do you taste the Yuzu do
you taste the pepper yes delicious so if
you want to try some snacks with us and
support this channel in the process then
click the link in the description and
use code trash taste to get 15 off your
first box stop eating we're getting more
hungry man I can smell that from here
what do you mean to do man it's okay
making the boxer for sponsoring this
episode this episode is sponsored by
Harry's boys are you taking care of how
you look I drive I try do you not want
the quickest and easiest way to take
care of yourselves we all got some beers
right of course of course well thanks to
Harry's we have to worry no more yay
whether your ritual is minimal or
elevated level up your shave game with
Harry's sleekest razor yet that
Innovative design delivers the same
great shave you expect with German
engineered blades that Glide across your
skin experience the latest and greatest
in Harry's Razer lineup delivered
straight to your door for just ten
dollars at harrys.com trash taste I've
been a Harry's SIM for as long as I can
remember but the first time I picked up
one of their blades I knew that I was in
for something special the fact that I
can keep the same blade for many shapes
without it darling and it still feels as
good as the first time I used it that's
when I knew
Harry's was for me but Connor did you
also know that you can schedule
replacement blade delivery whenever you
need them with refills as low as two
dollars
so elevate your shave with the latest
and greatest in Harry's razor handle
lineup today get your 17 craft handle
starter set for just ten dollars at
harrys.com trash taste that's harrys.com
trash taste it just doesn't make sense
they can't make money
regular Harris for sponsoring this
episode back to the show I guess I want
to bring things back to Trigon because
that was I I just finished watching that
like two uh no like three weeks ago I
finished watching it yesterday
it's fresh in my mind oh it was it was
insane uh you mentioned uh that the
author had a big hand in um in the
production of this is that normal for
like anime adaptations
normally I mean normally the author is
focused on drawing their manga right so
um people involved everyone involved
want to have that author do keep on
doing that yeah yeah so they might just
review
um certain key points of the production
right and even in Dragonstone beat
actually um NATO didn't review every
single uh details right but he reviewed
the the core part that really mattered
right right what is that core part so to
drink and party hard to understand each
other as much as possible at the start
of starting before even starting
anything oh yeah if you guys drinking
and eating together yeah so basically
talking about what movies do you like
what kind of designs do you like oh wow
the whole entire questions who are you
yeah and what did you mean to design
this was the entire question of having
them so kind of getting into the psyche
of the author right yeah okay that's a
that's a pretty cool method actually
rather than like doing a boring business
meeting of being like all right so uh
can you check uh to make sure that uh
vash's character design and everything
and the things he says is cool then
rather than just being like beer yeah
that character likes beer as well you
know when I was drunk as [__] and I was
writing this character this is how I
felt yeah I think I think that's a great
way of doing it because it's like
obviously you want to be able to get
into the head of the original Creator as
much as possible to make sure that you
don't have to keep like going back and
forth with them right to be like is this
correct is this correct so I mean like
how long is that process usually like
when when the the ball gets rolling it's
like okay we're doing new Trigon uh we
you know we want to make sure it's to
the likeness of the the what the author
envisioned so like how long is that I
guess just like incubation process of
making sure that everyone's on the same
wavelength yeah Trigon actually took
five years to holy [__] five years okay
I was thinking like a couple of months
or you know a year and
more those five years so that our first
year was definitely the Intensive part
right yeah I'm talking Knight to um what
what how do we understand you drinking
yeah
one year of drinks before we're happy to
proceed I mean it's not all drinks yeah
yeah just hanging out and chatting yeah
but yeah from there it started um then
how do we create this world so naito's
world is in the manga frame itself we
can't ask him to just draw the entire
what's not in the manga yeah because
he's working on guy sensing I mean
that's precious to him as well yeah
right right so then how can we make
something precious as equivalent or try
to at least match the preciousness of
what he created okay so we hired uh uh
actual sci-fi author to write down the
entire history for 150 years of history
from this this before the crash to the
crash oh wow so you you just have the
entire timeline of the world just laid
out oh wow Okay and like from there you
kind of like built up from that like one
timeline so from there um we decided
what to keep when not to keep what can
we describe what can we not describe
okay yeah how much of this timeline was
not in the show I'm I'm curious in terms
of like percentage percentage is
difficult but I mean was it like the
majority there's a lot of hundreds of
pages before the crash so a lot of it
that's not included there I don't know
what the crash is should I know what
that is so in 98 Dragon it's been so
long since I was okay yeah
yeah
um so it is okay how do you how do we
explain without spoiling okay yeah okay
okay now have we seen the original
Trigon yeah well it was in the original
Trigon animation yeah I forgot it's been
so long so in the original trigand even
though it's kind of like a western yeah
it's obviously not set on Earth yeah
right and so Humanity has found a way
there yeah uh and basically it turns
into kind of like a Sci-Fi yeah I
remember that aspects remember aliens
and I don't remember why
because I feel it's not until like the
last like four or five episodes yeah I
was like what I was like okay cool cross
girl
because because I feel like a lot of the
Sci-Fi aspects in the original Trigun
that was almost not like one of the core
aspects of the show it definitely came
in like halfway through but I feel like
Trigon Stampede the first big difference
I noticed was you're like from episode
one this is a Sci-Fi show we are leaning
into that right now
um was it was it part of the creative
decision to kind of like focus more on
the Sci-Fi aspects and focus on like the
World building yeah the director
um one of his Specialties is his
question in designing everything is
where are you from where are you going
right so in Dragon they had to know
where these characters are coming from
and what their objectives and where
they're going to then oh okay so so
going going back to the timeline how
much how much didn't or how much didn't
you put in the show how much did you
actually show out of everything that you
all this work that you did before in
terms of building this world well my
partner says that we could make like
five more shows
I feel I feel like you could release
that sci-fi book as like a like an
episode zero yeah you know like a light
novel of some kind I feel this because
like you could definitely feel you know
that would definitely in in the way that
the story was structured out when you
get to know more about the crash and the
history behind the crash there's
definitely a lot of Vital Information
there that is important to the present
day of whatever episode you're watching
which you know obviously is great
because it gets him way more invested
into the storytelling but there were
also a lot of details where I'm like
okay but I kind of want to know a little
bit more about this because that would
just get me even further invested but
obviously there's a 12 episode time
limit right so you can't [__] go all
out with it like you know the Dune movie
did the exact same thing where it's like
I'll give you a little sprinkle in some
like hints of backstory why is it always
12 or 24 episodes that's how the TV
structured process in Japan yeah okay I
was like damn there's gonna be a cool
reason
just TV contracts okay all right some of
them are good director streaming and
don't even air on TV in Japan so but
they still keep that 24 or 12. Netflix
doesn't you think about Edge Runners
that was 10 episodes I guess so yeah but
then even on Netflix a lot of the anime
dude still got 12 or and then you know
if you go to like if you go to like OVA
stuff like that like fully cooly was
only six episodes castlevania's started
off as four episodes and then Eight
Episodes so I mean I feel like it's the
difference between like let's say a
Netflix original produce anime and
something that Netflix just bought out
which that's like a big chunk though to
decide in one go like what if you have
like 16 episodes where he's like I guess
you just trim it down to try and find
stuff I mean that's the entire dilemma
every single yeah it's either too quick
or or way too slow yeah so that's based
on manga it could be ideally 16 episodes
but they've only used 12 so what do they
do yeah okay so like oh [__] I have so
many questions but I guess go go into
the manga thing so you have a manga you
have to adapt like like let's say Trigon
or B Stars
how do you position it so that the
season ends on like a banger you know on
like what feels like a season ending and
what if what if there's no what if what
if there's no like natural Breaking
Point what's what's the creative process
around condensing everything into 12
episodes
so um in case of B Star isn't even
Trigon um what we do is same we actually
take everything apart first right and we
look at what what is the tempo of the
film what is the tempo of the story and
what's the um how can we keep everything
but still not I'm some part we had to
cut it all out right right so basically
everything is kind of like you
everything has to be planned around like
kind of like a self-contained story arc
is what I'm what I'm getting all right
so you know going back to Trigon you
have your you have your timeline what
what comes next after the timeline so
timeline as we're developing timeline
we're developing concept Arts so then it
comes into what ideas can emerge from
the storyline visually okay so I mean we
hired uh we were working with tajimakoji
he's the guy behind like who designed
the new Venom in the live action Venom
okay okay and so he's an accident he
he's amazing so each day he draws dozens
of images right and he he drew 400
images for try to
just just concept art yeah concept
though I mean I've seen I've seen a lot
of bookstores in Japan where they just
sell straight up books filled with these
concept Arts right and it's literally
like big enough for a lot of series to
just fill an entire book right and you
know some of these images you've never
seen in the show it's just like to get a
Vibe or a feel of this is what the world
and story and characters is going to be
like yeah okay yeah so 400 um we used it
some of her promotion but most of the
design is entirely different because the
idea is what really matters there so at
this point how many years into
production are you in so this is still
the first year it's still first year has
the script in written yet no okay okay
okay
um so you have okay so you have your
concept art and then I guess you kind of
like narrow down what kind of vibe yeah
so we made the found the entire
Foundation into the year right then from
the foundation we started writing the
script okay okay okay at this point was
character design like a thing or no
design is has a purpose right right like
uh industry industrial design right
always has a purpose um was the concept
for a trailer okay so it's not that I
like the style design I don't like the
design it's why are you designed that
way it doesn't work in the world that
it's set in right so it's like
can you break down what concept art kind
of like is well what is it that is being
drawn and what kind of like thing is
being built on
so for example
um like create um it's really just kind
of hard to describe without the concept
the feeling yeah like a feeling yeah
like I mean it what Inspire I mean it's
something definitely what that concept
part does it how much can we Inspire the
the scriptwriter the director the
designer right to give more of a picture
of the world yeah I suppose I'm gonna
flush it out because I'm yeah I mean I
I'm [__] stupid if I don't see a
picture of something I'm like I can't
imagine that like to me that doesn't
mean anything I'm a visual learner like
I'm just straight up dumb
I don't get a picture I'm like what am I
what am I reading here so it sounds like
the concept art is like for more of the
better terms it's like a Vibe check
right to just be like here is the the
general overarching uh feel and Vibe of
the wall and then from there you kind of
start honing into the details as you go
into like character design and all that
kind of stuff is that concept yeah
that's Concepts so in the original
Trigon anime is designed as Western yeah
so there's is Western inspired so
there's what made things made out of
wood yeah yeah but if we're taking this
sci-fi approach
um this is a desert Planet there's no
plants there's no kind of plants so if
civilization human civilization brought
in a crashed ship there's no wood used
on the ship yeah so where does this word
come would come so it doesn't come from
anywhere
never thought about that so in this new
dragon Stampede we don't have any wood
architecture unless it's a this one
origin called plants um it's not it's
not um same as plants are the trees but
right I never never thought about that
oh my God because when you when you see
like the towns and cities in Trigon it
just I can't explain it it just feels
like yeah that that could be real it's
sometimes you just watch a show where
the world just makes sense on a
subconscious level do you know what I
mean where sometimes you watch a show
um or play a game and you're like I
don't know why this world operates this
way yeah you can't really
you already say why it doesn't make
sense just something just feels wrong
but one thing I got from watching Trigon
Stampede is that it feels like a world
that just exists yeah like you don't
stop to question it you don't stop the
question you know it's not like every
detail is spelled out but it feels like
you your brain just accepts it on a
subconscious level and I I guess I'm
like kind of figuring out why that is
now yeah I mean we figured out we
thought about
how's the population ratio of this
crashed ship what did they focus on so
the Asian population focuses on here
other population Focus here how did
these people communicate so the trade
route should be focused like that so
those are all the things we thought
about exactly how deeply did you go into
like like these little details yeah the
macroeconomics I mean the book is like
the space Oh my God
oh my God yeah you're basically like
recreating a civilization from scratch
yeah that's wild I thought that probably
game creators are probably doing like
this oh yeah yeah sure yeah you play
Destiny you're like go online to
download the 19 page PDF to find out why
this rock is bullied they're like what
the [__] I don't want to do that it's
like some Lord of the Rings [__] what do
you guys explain stuff to me what the
hell
so this was all done within like the
first year uh I mean that took I mean
we're starting to go into the later
years too as well okay so everything is
going in perils right so everything is
going in parallel so at which point did
like the scripts die being written and
like let's say the character designs
start being like finalized yeah after
the first year we started going into
designs and the script writing right but
to finalize that we we took three years
so
oh [__] okay is it is in your experience
is this like normal for an anime
production okay I mean orange itself um
is uh uncommon for a anime production we
took three years right where industry
standards like two yeah yeah yeah that's
what I thought isn't that crazy to think
like you say three years very casually
but that's the time that trash taste has
been around
isn't that wild to think about you guys
have a trusty Sammy if we started
working on episode one it would be done
right about now that's crazy oh my God
yeah it's it's interesting that you had
so much concept art done because I kind
of just assumed that because there was
like pre-existing material like manga
like like a manga there that there
wouldn't be there wouldn't need to be
this much work to be done in
pre-production I mean there's also a
previous anime previous anime as well
but I guess I I guess this is like the
work that you don't really think about
or you don't really see I'm I'm curious
because you mentioned earlier as um you
know your job to find the the money to
fuel the anime surely when the show
takes five years
that's a lot more money that we got to
get a hold of how do you kind of I mean
how do you convince people to be like
it'll make enough money trust me it'll
it'll work what's that whole I'm just so
interested about the financials of it
all because it seems like such a kind of
an industry that doesn't have a lot of
money but somehow it always just turns
up and it's like we'll figure it out so
a lot of Japan is not really uh legal
culture so it's a lot about trust yeah
worldwide so I mean we orange luckily
had a track record of making amazing
shows yeah right animation at least so
um we basically were building on that
trust working on that trust right
constantly um just saying that it's
gonna be okay
and so as a because I'm I don't know how
any of this works you know as a studio
that actually makes the show how is it
the studio actually makes money from
these shows is it you know what kind of
uh Revenue ways of getting revenue is
there for this yes uh it depends on from
it really depends on on the show widely
on how each show is no okay um for
Orange um the primary is we work for
hire so we got hired by a client to do
one show okay okay that makes way more
sense I thought it was like okay guys we
gotta we gotta sell this many REM
figures oh we're going broke this [__]
all right crack open the savings account
boys like whatever everyone pitching a
thousand dollars all right boys we'll
make taking a ram spin-off you know
we've got to get those finger sales up
guys actually you know I always wondered
how you know because it seemed like it
was a lot of different rates holders and
a lot of different parties at play and
it seems like a really complicated
massive who gets what money and why
there's so many different things and
wait why is RAM on a Pachinko machine
what the hell yeah it's like a bunch of
different things going on it always
seems just kind of like a yeah trust me
yeah trust me it'll be fine another
approach a lot of the time so how long
does it take to produce a single episode
of anime let's say like a single 20
minute episode of anime in in your
experience how long does that take so um
a normal production would say like three
months but that's not for orange normal
production right um in Orange's case we
actually uh make three episodes about
three episodes at once right and then
find what's the quality line and then
based off their make the rest other
episodes right so that first three
episodes is a benchmark maker what do
you mean by the quality line I mean so
like this is the quality Benchmark that
we're trying to set
well you set yourself a really hope yeah
I've seen that first episode yeah
yeah it's so high
oh so you could be like guys pop the
brakes on this one let's make this
shittier we got to make 50 goddamn apps
we're gonna slow down I just like the
thing like how many times for every
single project I say we are doing better
than any other show so it's your job
guys make it worse please stop this I
just like to imagine like episode one
just like airs for everyone in this
studio to watch everyone's just sweating
yeah being like oh [__] we're gonna top
this yeah it does feel like when you're
you know when your older brother is like
smart you're like [__] sake man really
I look worse be dumb because like I
remember like Dragon Stampede episode
when it opens on a scene where it's like
um it's like the spaceship is like
exploding and you see uh fashion nice uh
like flying out yeah like whizzing
around and I remember watching I was
like God damn yeah I suppose you you
watched down you're like this we got 12
episodes of this now we're gonna keep up
too that was okay that was okay when I
saw a 12 episode
um the when they were doing it I'm like
I messaged my uh everyone in the company
I'm like how are you doing this
it's like we're [__] boys I've noticed
it now because there is so much anime
being made it's like more compete like
competitive than ever in terms of like
shows that you got to compete with
there's a lot more pressure to make like
episode one a standout episode to get
people's attention do you have that
thought mindset going into like
producing an anime that you have to make
episode one stick or land as soon as
possible or is that something that it's
not really thought about
it's I mean definitely it's a weekly
show so the first episode really matters
right
um also we in our mind for our based on
our successful experience with
landlustious yeah is that first three
episodes to really really matter the
three episodes
was based on a movie uh the three
three-part uh I don't know the English
Trilogy no no uh uh how it's act one act
two oh yeah
so it's based on three act rules so the
first three episodes was the first act
right right from there it changes the
tone again right would you say that
Trigon was the hardest production you've
been involved with yes every single
production is always hard but it just
updates whatever it just gets harder and
harder and harder yeah how was uh
working on B Stars compared to Trigon
[Laughter]
Stars our animator took one week to do
one shot and Dragon stampy took three
weeks to one shot
[Music]
I mean I guess you know if you have to
animate clothes uh on characters and
Trigon versus
oh the face yeah because like I noticed
I'm not sure if this was always the case
but I definitely noticed in Trigun that
you guys lip synced the audio which
which I'm like you're not using like the
three frames of the mouth like that I'm
used to you actually like going frame by
frame and animating the facial
expressions as well which I I which is
one thing that like really stood out to
me yeah so how do so going going to be
stars then how was that pre-production
did was there as much time put into
let's say the World building and the
vibe
um going into that production uh these
Stars kiss we never um I mean the
original intention for our producing is
that we love B Stars yeah and um the
whole the producing team was that the
first page was there let's adapt this as
it is to animation so it wasn't that as
hard as that okay
they're like involved as much as like
Nitro since it was with face towels uh
in different ways so in her case
um she wasn't as she used to and she
doesn't um she wasn't really familiar
first of all anime right so she was a
lot more female
um experience of film oh so for us um
our challenge was can we
um
show this as a film to her and it's just
something passable to her that explains
so that's crazy the thing that you would
you like the whole way the show is made
is like just to kind of I guess please
one person potentially that's so odd to
think it's also odd to think that she
was never into anime considering she's
the daughter of [__] the creator of
buggy like you think you'd be into a
movie an anime for a long time right I
guess I mean there was the 90s scrapple
Bucky anime but yeah well I I think
that's part of the big reason why like
you know B Stars just I don't know
something about the vibe just didn't
feel like yeah it makes so much sense
because I feel unlike a lot of manga
stories out there the flow of B Stars
definitely feels more like a live-action
film than a standard manga I'm just
gonna say it's very weird yeah this is
weird is there ever a point where you
guys are anime and then she's like
you're like what the [__] is this you're
like oh my God what are we animating
like it's like okay boys I don't know
how he told you this but we can gonna
have to animate a rabbit having sex with
a deer
they're just like okay
you're like all right let's just let's
just watch the rabbits so you're like
all right boys we're going to the strip
club we're going to research we're gonna
go on and on locations we did go to the
strip club
sorry to be
a cool dancing club
okay you guys right you guys taking
notes yes
it's research purposes it's because that
there's a pole dancing character
and I was like what am I watching yeah
season one I could get away with saying
I wasn't a fury but season two it's just
getting harder to argue this oh no I
went into the anime already a furry like
I was I was already converted I just
need to ask why did you have to make
Juno so hot yeah uh honestly wait what
does that look what does that look why
did you have to make it so hot every
single character in that show is hot oh
no okay
I will admit Legacy also hot uh but do
you know I don't know what it is about
Juno that awoke something in me because
she I think single-handedly turned me
into a furry I think there's something
wrong with my brain I can only Envision
the deer is called Stanley I don't know
why
I always figure Stanley in my head
he would have been such a different
anime
is also horses and yeah I just like I
remember that scene I think it was like
end of season one we're done right
[Applause]
why don't these just do that in real
life
by the man who made back you without
telling you
got it it was just that scene where it
was like Juno and Louis together
like she's just on top of him I'm just I
could feel neurons just firing that's so
weird this sounds weird anyone who
hasn't seen Beast I can only get Soul
wrecked
it could be a lot of less what we do is
that it's more kept oh yeah I was going
to go into that actually so I assume
that most 3D Studios don't do mocap a
lot of three Studios do mocap but right
they use it totally different from away
from us so how do you guys use it as
opposed to others so for us it's only a
reference so for example you know how
Pixar animators they act on camera yeah
and made their scene yeah basically
we're just doing that in mocap so all
our animators are doing the motion
capture oh okay oh okay how extensively
is that used is that like every scene or
just uh every physically doable scene so
it's just regular just talking like this
right um our animes do it but if it's
like dancing fighting martial art and
stuff yeah we have higher professional
people today you have to hire like a
professional martial artists oh wow oh
that's cool or professional motion
capture yeah oh wow how does that work
so they come into the studio one day and
you kind of like
okay this is do you come up with the
choreography or do you get them to come
up with the fight choreography usually
we hire someone to come up with a
choreography right right so how does
that read in a script versus how how
like what seeing why this took five
years yeah yeah
getting these steps on more than I
thought it was just some dude just
playing around with a model
I was just wiggling it around what the
hell
are people it's like I'm super curious
so like let's say in the script there's
a scene in Trigun bash fights a baddie
or something how much detail was in the
script that's the choreographer has to
work with to I guess make the make the
action scene action scene actually
relies heavily more on storyboard so in
the script it could be just like one
line at times okay okay I feel because
like yeah Vash is kind of I feel a
little bit different because his a lot
of his movements are just very animated
like to the point where it's almost like
it's it's the kind of comedic like
animated where it's like oh that's
clearly the movements of a cartoon
character or like an anime character
right it's like a lot of movements where
it's like a human couldn't possibly do
that kind of movement but it's
believable because it's not a real actor
you're looking at yeah kind of thing so
I feel that kind of movement would be
super hard for like a mocap actor to do
yeah yeah I mean I feel like especially
watching vash's like a lot of his
character is to do is in his animation
especially when he's like pirouetting
round bullets and yeah all that kind of
stuff
um so so in terms of like story like
storyboarding I guess uh going back to
the timeline of like an anime being made
so you you have the script and then does
the storyboard come after that and then
yeah and the scripts finalized we start
doing storyboard right so in our case um
we do something called pre-scoring after
that so instead of recording um most
Animes in Japan record after the when
they start doing animation but for us we
do recording before we start doing
animation because we want to make all
the pacing of the film before Iron Man
was going I guess that explains the
perfect lip syncing then because I was
like that would have been harder to make
a film to make a film yes it's weird how
to get better animation usually bring
more human involvement in the animation
yeah basically our concept is that how
can we use the experience but instead of
relying solely on people experience how
do we make that as a system
so if we could adapt that experience
into a system first then next project we
could use that system as a foundation to
get gain more experience right right
okay how many how many shows did you end
up working on like simultaneously is it
only like one at a time or do you do you
like have multiple shows that you're
being worked on it depends on time to
time but usually two shows at a time per
animation we're playing um as a producer
I'm working like five six different
shows right now oh wow how do you like
just organize that all like I mean I
have some assistant producers right or
some projects I'm more emotionally
involved in right right invested in is
there so I don't give a [__] about this
show too much give it to the assistant
no every show to Orange matters of
course of course we can't miss I mean we
spent
[Music]
that's why they're the goat I agree
actually I agree I agree yeah it takes
two years for us to develop a show so
have you ever said no to be like I don't
think we would we could do this or I
don't know I mean there's a lot of times
we say that okay okay is it due to like
personal reasoning or like more like a
technical like limit or I mean it's
mostly technical right so I mean if they
were giving this certain manga and
there's like 100 as I said they're 100
characters right right we simply can't
do this is is there any like dream shows
that you want to work on or that you
would love is there a show where it's
like orange if orange did this show yeah
it would be a banger I'm working on this
so I can't say it
you can tell us after the show then
we'll oh
damn oh no I'm excited because yeah so
when is the show ending I just want to
know right now uh a question that uh is
often asked nowadays is um you know
because you do a lot of 3D animation and
right now there's a massive conversation
around like Ai and all that stuff do you
feel that there's any possibility in the
future where it somehow helps make anime
or helps the production aspect in any
form or could it be seen as perhaps a
detriment to the current model that 3D
Studios might have
I mean there's there's the there's many
issues of revolving AI there's the
morale issue there's the legal issue and
I can't even specify which issue they
have right now yeah
yeah I mean unless we're able to feel
comfortable with that
um We're Not Gonna utilize as a tool I
mean everything eventually is a tool for
us yeah yeah but without that issue it's
solved we can't really use it yeah
because like what is the general Vibe
around AI in like the Japanese animation
industry right now because we have a
vibe from Twitter
I mean that's what this Vibe is always
bad yeah that's the only thing I
actually know because oh really I don't
interact with the rest of the industry
anymore oh okay because to us it's about
how can we make ourselves better yeah
yeah so I mean using other parts of the
industry is not really don't have enough
time to care about the resume industry
it's like we're just here to make
bangers damage yeah I mean it sounds
selfish but I mean it's our problems
that we're facing right now of course
yeah how do I solve our problems not
other people's problems no definitely
has this conversation cropped up into
orange at all like the conversation of
AI we always have the conversation but
right now is not yet okay yeah I mean
yeah maybe in the future if things
settle but oh yeah right I guess because
there's always like you know softwares
that have like Smart Tools right like
there's some things that'll you know you
can tell it hey I mean like in a weird
way I guess like fell on paint right
yeah the whole thing yeah in between all
it's like I guess there's always that
line that's kind of difficult with some
tools that make doing certain kind of
things an animation or whatever easier
that would technically be clashes AI but
on it's just morally using the whole
take everyone's [__] input and then
blur something out it's kind of like
getting that balance of tools that are
useful and made ethically uh between the
whole let's make an anime for me yeah
it's like so what Point are you is it
morally right to automate the process
yeah right where it's like if it's too
automated then is it even it's not a
person making any sort of like how how
was that automation being done right
what is it learning from was this maybe
even stealing from right yeah um I guess
that's the moral quandary of it all I
mean right now I mean we debug two our
own tools oh so I mean not AI tools and
just tools yeah absolutely I mean to
have things experience of 10 then we
make the tool then that will create us a
equivalent of experience of three so we
haven't been off to our new grads then
use that then they instantly start off
from three so that's our way of thinking
what did you mind elaborating on what
tools that you have so I mean uh one
would be the automorph face so one thing
is that CG and hand drawn the most most
diff major differences that CG is
three-dimensional hand-drawn is not yes
um it might look three dimensional but
Comfort level doesn't have to be
three-dimensional to create comfort so a
lot of manga is actually not
three-dimensional it looks realistic
yeah but it's not three-dimensional yeah
because like I guess there's
there's always like the uh challenge of
you know having a 3D model
um is great but making sure that it
looks good on camera I guess which is
two-dimensional which is a you know a
two-dimensional thing and you had to
create a like a specific tool just for
that so we have a tool called automorph
where we point the camera to a character
and that model would automatic warp wow
so it could just decide just completely
warp this way to make sure that on the
camera it looks really natural so like
sideways manga characters will have two
eyes where it physically it's impossible
because they're nine degrees Yeah but in
our Automotive it automatically warped
it so that oh [__] okay okay so you're
kind of playing around with so you're
morphing the face to play around with
perspective yes to make it look more
naturally like I guess two-dimensional
right yeah you guys developed that
in-house in-house oh wow that's cool
because as experienced we know how to do
it by hand but yeah we're physically
changing the model every single shot
that's just like kind of like almost
like presets a little bit it's like okay
if camera here warped the face yeah
because have you seen the behind the
scenes of like some of the JoJo openings
uh I don't actually know oh because like
there are some shots yeah those those
are 3D and there are some shots with
some like the poses and you there's like
been some screenshots of like what it
looks like out of like the camera
perspective and like I remember seeing
one where I I think it's like Joseph's
hand was like just like warps like
ridiculously when it was doing like one
of the posts it looks it looks so
ridiculous uh when you just change the
perspective just a little bit but on
camera looks really cool yeah I guess uh
that's one thing I wanted to ask is like
when you guys wanted to yeah obviously
you know the main goal with orange is to
be like all right how do we make the 3D
animation look as pristine and as
comfortable for people who are more used
to just watching 2D animation as
possible uh when it came to that like
obviously there's been like past and
different Studios who have done 3D
animation with varying success have you
ever like gone to like look at some of
the maybe the older shows that have used
maybe a little more like primitive 3D to
kind of like get a hint of like okay
maybe if we work on this then it won't
end up like this show or like do you use
it as a reference to be like okay this
is what not to do so let's not do what
they did in this show and instead try
and fix that in our show it's more
scarce that it's actually trial and
they're on their own thing right so we
try it start making it and it doesn't
work then we keep go back to the
scratchboard do it again so you never
look back at like old shows to be like
that really sucks not really okay that's
good to know I mean there's actually a
lot of things to focus on I mean if
they're doing people other people are
doing better then it's more time it's
more better to use on analyzing that
right right I find it really interesting
to use the word Comfort when watching
animation that's seems it kind of makes
sense why you would say the word Comfort
but
it seems very unusual to describe
animation as being comfortable right but
I suppose when we talk about 3D where
often the major complaint is that it's
it looks weird The Uncanny this year
yeah so what is it that like why do some
shows just not get that right like what
is the main thing that is the common
mistake that happens when we're talking
about 3D enemies because it's 3D yeah
yeah it's 3D why is that better I don't
know I mean they're trying to make look
something that's really not 3D so that
causes a come through right so it's kind
of like a uh I'm kind of kind of like an
uncanny valley effect so it's a little
bit different from The Uncanny value
that Pixar and stuff ran into first
right but since we're trying to shade
then we run into a different candy
is basically the cell look the
hand-drawn type of look right that you
do in 3D okay so do you specifically try
to I guess emulate the anime style do
you want your shows be seen like a 2d
show or kind of like something a bit
different from like your typical 2D
anime we start out I mean when we
started doing animation it's just
whatever we able to do at the time yeah
yeah we started as a work for hire for
other hand-drawn Studios right so we're
required to look something create
something that blends into their yeah
art style so that's where we started out
yeah because you guys worked uh like
co-worked on Black Bullet right yeah so
like what was the main role of Studio
Orange in that show ah I can't really
like backgrounds and stuff or there
should be some enemies I think that
appear in Black Bullet right or CGS oh
okay that was before my time so sorry
right no no okay yeah do you do less of
that work that kind of work now in terms
of like working on other shows uh in
terms of like 3D CD elements and now do
most mostly focus on your own stuff yeah
I mean focusing on what our own stuff
was our Dream okay so we remained in
that but I mean sometimes we have some
open time so in that times we work for
hire for other Studios still so okay
what's her second or Community your
first like fully Studio orange producer
okay how did that come about were you
was that so um it was actually how the
project started was before any producer
existed at Orange oh okay um it was the
the producer for B stars and Trigun
wanted to do an industrious at Orange
right right and then my partner Waki was
called in from
like uh
movie oh yeah oh yeah yeah so he's the
first producer to exist in Orange oh
okay okay and I kind of like it must
have been I guess daunting to be like
again we're just going to do a 3D
produce anime now we've never been
officially when like came out and I
think it was at like the peak of the 3D
anime equals bad stigma right and then
all of a sudden you have a fully 3D
anime Atlanta lustrous which you know at
the time had a very dedicated like manga
fan base as well right yeah I'm sure
like did you guys like get any initial
backlash win it first came out or were
people like pleasantly surprised about
how did you think no one really expected
anything until it came out right yeah
how did it came out suddenly so yeah how
did you convince the producers to be
like yeah okay trust us trust us we
haven't got anything to uh anything to
prove ourselves but trust our resume is
practically empty but we can do it
especially we did some character
animation before that illustrious but
not as a non-worker right did you have
to like
because I I guess like my the first
thing comes to mind is I remember like I
saw a documentary of when Jurassic Park
was being made there was a conversation
about whether we should do these
dinosaurs in uh you know uh stop motion
or in 3D and the VX company had to make
like just a Showcase of what they could
do did Studio orange need to do
something similar as well going into it
no I mean from the start was that it was
already decided that they wanted to do
in 3D right they wanted to land luscious
at Orange so the producer's job is like
figure out
[Laughter]
we have this daunting task for you
figure your [__] out like what the [__]
I compared to I mean I guess 2D anime
has something kind of similar where I
imagine that with technology improving
it it makes it easier was there like a
was it like big leaps at all in the past
like since land of lustrous that have
kind of made it easier or uh made
production smoother well we've done in
the past is a lot easier because we
haven't put it into tools right but
because of that time that we have we're
challenging new stuff it's never easy
for anything right yeah I've I've
noticed like I it feels like to me at
least they're from every show you guys
have produced you've always stepped up
in some different ways so even if you
made a bangership already you're like
how do we do with this better how do we
do this better yeah because like like I
I didn't think you guys could top B
stars and you did thank you it was it
was nuts like yeah episode I don't even
want to know how long episode 12. oh my
God Trigun took to produce
that last fight scene episode 12 is nuts
yeah yeah I'll go watch it actually
insane for B Stars how did you go about
animating like animal characters and
giving them like the same
animalistic character animalistic
characters that each I guess animal has
so B stars um we start from I mean they
have human traits as animals yeah so
what's the balance between that so
um we started looking at the what it
called the
anatomy yeah so how does animal muscle
facial structure happen why do animals
not smile
how can we make these creatures smile
right right was the first starting point
so you literally went he literally had
to break down each animal's Anatomy did
that go into like the modeling of all of
the characters as well oh my God I mean
like if animals don't have this muscle
and this muscle right so they can't make
um the rich Expressions humans it's
impossible for them all right so
yeah because I guess that must have been
like a like an uncanny valley that would
have been difficult to overcome because
it's like if you just added those
muscles in to the model then I'm sure
like the first couple of like prototypes
must have looked like super janky right
yeah yeah how much research did you have
to do in each animal before even like
modeling I mean that's that's the reason
three years
for three years I talked to the animals
smile damage we'll have a real child
Studio animals that was the real
challenge
I'm sorry I'm sorry
yeah so yet three years of research yeah
I mean two years of research two years
of research Jesus just
I mean research is just in books or
photos or videos but also research
actually putting into model and it's
working working is this three years
after like hey we've signed a contract
being like let's make the show we've
been we've been uh brought in to do this
you know how do you then explain I
assume to like a client it's got to be
kind of tough to be like hey just give
them a little while they're just
figuring things out like how does that
all conversation go I mean that's the
conversation we have to have for Trigon
yeah you're just like hey just trust me
we're gonna figure it out oh I mean
Trigon um we since a producer for a
Trigon on our client side is a producer
who worked for not lusherson he starts
we knew each other yeah so we had a lot
of very mutual trust and we're not going
to hide stuff we're showing him yeah
this is the process we're doing right
now yeah how much do you you kind of
like need to network as an anime
producer in terms of meeting other
people in the industry
um as of I used to be a hand-drawn side
right but Henry on Thai was demented
because I had to collect every single
animator myself too oh geez not every
single but a lot of the key figures yeah
yeah but for Orange um production we all
of our animals are in-house okay so I
don't have to do that on that side it's
to me who am I going to find for the key
staff so the scriptwriter director
um episode director and such so is that
in-house as well
okay so you literally have to like go
out to the industry and see who is
available to work on this one show for
these specific roles yes why wouldn't
you have those people in-house like
what's the benefit to having them
um picking at uh writers and stuff some
people we have in-house but each project
gets so different I mean what's required
so different art style is different
storytelling is different makes sense so
right okay how
how accurate is shiribako I've always
because like as an anime viewer when we
talk about anime production you know
there is a lot more resources out right
now but to like I say somebody's not too
deep into the field a lot of people look
at shirobaka as being like this is this
is a documentary base yeah yeah I've had
so many instances of someone like giving
me like a tidbit on like oh this is how
the anime production works and I'm like
what's your source and they're like
shirabaka episode seven and I'm like
okay but maybe some of it is like
dramatized so yeah yeah I mean papers I
mean he's using strickens is of course
as a fiction
um I mean I was never involved in
shirogo itself yeah I mean it's a lot of
the Israel so and we're driving to pick
up um animation from animators we see
other Studio rival Studios we do stare
at each other like this and like start
revving the end
I mean we all we all make sure that we
are not
yeah
it's like yeah
Luigi death stare each other
feels so exciting and real because that
is based on a lot of people's experience
yeah is is it normal for like an episode
to be finished just before it like airs
on TV uh for our case I mean that's not
the style we choose anymore yeah but I
mean in my past um career I have had
that kind of situation as my God was it
like pretty often or was it like kind of
like a one-off
I I could call it often
who's got the good PC to render this end
I had a time where I thought how I
comfortably sleep at the studio was an
amazing thing but I I'm really glad now
that I don't have to sleep in a studio
at all so that's good that's good did
you have to sleep like you got to do
previous roles did you have to sleep
there how often did you have to sleep at
the studio well I mean cardboard is
comfortable oh no
sleeping bag on the cardboard is even
more comfortable
sleeping under a meeting desk is really
comfortable because there's no light
coming on oh no so get this episode out
I haven't seen my wife in three days how
much is like the office would uh you
know obviously in the past how much of
the office like percentage-wise would
end up just sleeping at the office
sentence sentence is difficult because I
mean everyone's doing different jobs
yeah yeah yeah but like it must be like
a giant sleepover if everyone's just
kind of everywhere everyone's at the end
I mean there's certain a couple couches
that's in the studio okay sometimes it
was a fight to get that cuts dude
I I recently filmed something at a
different Anime Studio
um and I I turned up at like 3 P.M to
film something and uh it was people
people were coming in just from waking
up and I was like what they just woke up
it's 3 P.M I mean that could be that
might not not necessarily be overworking
I mean yeah the whole just like living
I didn't get that impression but I got
the impression of like oh it's it's
animators they walk on their own time
yeah the sleep schedule is a suggestion
when it gets done it gets done well you
don't have to be awake while everyone
else is awake as long as you get your
work done did you get those eight hours
and you get those animations done who
cares I mean nowadays things are
becoming digital so yeah assistance
going in cars but back then cars was a
thing so
um if there's traffic that means we have
to spend more time yeah
so like I guess you don't have to like
like name any names or anything like
that but like
when when when an anime production does
go wrong you know when when you see the
final product and it's not like not
necessarily Studio orange just in
general the anime industry what goes
into what mistakes go into
uh like an anime production that might
not have the final products that the
people working on it want to have
like because it seems like a lot of it
is from the planning stages and I'm
curious yeah what actually what actually
goes wrong in that sense there's there's
thousands of array of things that needs
to be careful about instant production
right so honestly um as a production
management
um
the amount of information that you have
to manage is a very
very
intense variety I think even missing one
of them will can be led to that you need
to give some examples of what kind of
like information
um it's like scheduling or it's been a
while so I tried to remember my memory
yeah because it's I'm like as an anime
producer I'm sure you have to like
manage a lot of different things so how
long how long has has it been since you
joined orange again it's been five years
for me okay five years so cool enough to
make one show
I mean covert did special thing to me it
kind of like a lot of my memory before
that's that's that's Humanity that's
just Humanity yeah the symptoms of like
long coveted you like a memory gets
worse is it
I met a I met someone who was like yeah
my memory's been crap since I got
covered I'm like wait is this real I
looked it up yeah apparently you can
some people got memory issues Jesus if
you've got long covered holy [__] I was
just always done so like it actually
didn't do anything
yeah let me rephrase the question what
are some things to avoid to have a
successful anime production in your
opinion uh to have a well communication
um everything everything yeah right I
mean to you have to communicate you
can't refuse to communicate I mean you
constantly have to be keep on up up on
everything information I feel that
applies to just most businesses though
right it's like one miscommunication and
just [__] goes array yeah yeah I I
remember like growing up
is I remember growing up like in
University or something like that yeah
every every job would be picking up the
communication skills yeah and I remember
always thinking as a teenager I'm like
what what [__] skills is there is
there to do just just talk bro just talk
yeah that you all at every job
interviews how good are your
Communications yeah I'm like I know
English
yeah but like yeah especially working in
like I worked as like a project
management I realized oh communication
is definitely a skill and there are some
people that suck at it
um and you have no idea how much a
project can go wrong whether it be an
animation or any kind of other project
you're managing just because people
don't feel like talking about it yeah
people just don't talk about everything
um and I kind of I can only imagine with
how many moving Parts there are in the
animation industry because like on on a
general project how many people are
involved so uh when I was doing a
production assistant I was in charge of
20 animators right so I had to look over
the progress of doing different
animators for three months and six
months right right and then so intense
itself is intensive because they're not
necessarily in the studio they could be
working somewhere else right and I had
to call them they might not pick up then
I'll call them again they don't pick up
yeah I'll call them again
so if they call and pick up a
communicate that's just a really amazing
enemy just to me
at the time
but nowadays I mean if you look at the
credits there's like hundreds of
animators right right I mean I can't I
mean back then my what I experienced and
things people experience now is totally
different I can't even imagine what
people are going through right now
because I've been away from that side
yeah yeah because it seems like a lot of
the time especially talking to you know
kenato the other animator we had on is
that it's it becomes common I guess I'm
not sure how common it actually is but
it seems like it's common for a lot of
anime products to be let's say behind
schedule right and I guess I want I
wonder how is is it because the
estimation is wrong or is it a different
thing every time that so many anime
projects always seem to be behind
schedule and it seems to be a lot of
crunch in like the animation industry I
think every situation is different but a
lot of times a lot of people are trying
to make it better right their ambition
is very big ah okay it could be some
individual level to a production level
and right I feel that's yeah because I
especially recently I feel there's just
been so many more news articles coming
out about this anime has been delayed
this anime has been delayed and I feel
like I'm sure there's been delays over
you know the entire history of anime
production but like it's something about
just recently have you noticed this as
well so many shows are getting delayed I
mean that's I feel like it's one thing
it's yeah maybe you know but people are
taking more time I hope so and I feel
like that's just kind of like a symptom
with many more anime shows being made so
yeah a lot of them are going to be
delayed I guess I hope I just hope that
it is because of a quality issue and not
like say like oh the the guy creating
the schedule just [__] up and
overestimated everything right well it
seems like it sounds like for me a lot
of people in the anime industry are just
perfectionists yeah
yeah I mean I understand if they wait a
day longer they might get something
better yeah before one day I mean if I
was working on one project for five
years I'd probably be a perfectionist
but look at me like yes Don is good
enough whatever Orange it's totally done
differently right um we actually
simulate the entire production
um because we we don't do that there's
gonna be a piece that's missing we're
gonna be [__] we can't actually get
past that piece yeah yeah right because
if it's hand run they'll just say it
didn't just draw it yeah if it's CC if
it tools can't do that we can't do that
we can't get over there we can't say oh
we need this toolbar tomorrow yeah that
doesn't happen
Okay so sorry I'm just thinking about
how
um you know I guess Japan is kind of
notorious having a pretty pretty brutal
work-life balance an anime even is even
more so like you mentioned in times you
sleep on the floor you know it sounds
like Studio orange is also a lot more
forward-thinking kind of modern
when it comes to the approach of of that
just wondering like what are you do you
have any thoughts on crunch or
um what's the difference between Crunch
and just normal Japanese Fork life
balance which it sounds like everyone is
in crunch all the time in Japan I think
it's because um our way of thinking is
different is because that we're not
technology Anime Studio we're CG studio
and that first of all because the
workforce comes from uh Workforce that
we share with gaming right so I mean
when people get out of college or
whatever the school or they train
themselves we're constantly competing
with the gaming industry to get people
right so their starting point their
expectation in the what they look for
work is completely different right right
you're like hey we think you'd be great
for this oh so yeah that's the starting
point for us so that's why it's so
different
um what we do is very anime like right
how people come into the industry is
totally different right you kind of set
the standards to that more akin to like
the gaming industry than the standard
anime industry right so in our case like
it's 90 employee so there all are
employed instead of um hand-drawn that's
90 hand-drawn right right freelance
sorry yeah right and you're in your like
experience you know before orange how
much you know if there's an anime
production there how much would be like
in-house workers versus let's say
freelance animators or you know
animators outside of the studio before
Orange um before orange was all just
industry standard so mostly Freelancers
mostly Freelancers I mean yeah orange I
mean I'm not sure if this is something
we intended to go this way but I mean it
now it is so what I can keep it it is we
don't want to go into the 90 Freelancers
yeah because I I've noticed even now
like there's a lot like it didn't used
to be this way but I've noticed there
are a lot more people who you know maybe
I followed on Twitter
um just for like I like the artwork or
something and then I follow them for
like long enough time and they get
picked up by an Anime Studio or they end
up working on an anime project I'm like
when did this start to happen
what did they do before Twitter yeah
yeah exactly yeah I mean I can only
imagine because I'm not in that side
yeah I'm curious how how much do you pay
attention to like fan reaction in terms
of like Studio oranges
um in that case a lot oh really yeah um
I'm constantly on Twitter to look at
responses oh sorry I'm so sorry you have
to do that well I mean
um positive or negative it's all part of
the responses that we need right there's
gonna be one there you're like shut up
what are you you don't know [__]
no I mean I mean there's always a secret
season two please
you're nice I can't see anything because
it's not my position to say anything I'd
be like no I got you I got you you're a
piece I understand I totally understand
love to have it but I can't see it wait
b-star season three wins shut up
I mean I would love to talk about it but
not yet yeah right what is what is like
this is gonna sound so weird because
it's Twitter but what what is some
useful like responses
trick questions like I don't really
focus on individual responses it's
really the amount of energy where's the
energy Where is the expectation as a
whole yeah I think I think honestly we
do the same thing like we I don't read
you individual YouTube comments I'm just
like what's the vibe yeah the whole
comments like yeah what people feel you
know because you you can kind of get the
general kind of sentiment which I find
is more useful than just one guy who's
gonna be annoyed that you didn't draw
ligoshi with a bigger bulge or something
you know what I mean and I mean like
it's so helpful like getting the general
you said energy is so much more helpful
yeah sure yeah do you ever like
incorporate that into
what you know what feedback goes into
your future works or is it more just to
gen get the vibe of okay this show is
doing well right now people like people
like it I mean I think I really see
anime as something really fantastic yeah
um when I first discovered perfect blue
it was amazing
I didn't know anime could do this kind
of sensation to me yeah yeah so I want
to create that sensation to as much
people as possible oh [__] yeah and this
means that I want to create people to be
communicating via anime yeah so I mean
like you guys invited me for tracking
Stampede yeah having a conversation this
is what I wanted to do
so how can I do this with more people
right is what I focus on so using that
um what I learned from how people are
reacting try to implement on the
creative and the the business side yeah
as well you might have to watch it
because because
okay I'm curious because there is
something very specific about Trigun uh
because I like I was always planning to
do a video in it and I didn't have the
time unfortunately uh but it felt like
talk about it now yeah yeah because I my
gauge as just a viewer going through
comments and everything like that a big
complaint means when the series was
airing at least not when it was finished
was uh people just like OG fans of the
original Trigon being like this isn't
like the original try gun this feels
totally different vash's design is so
different like what are you what are you
doing and it seemed like reading from
like some some of the I guess interviews
that
uh that the creative team had done
before his release it it was almost like
you were maybe expecting it in a way
because I remember a big a big uh big
message was just like hey this isn't the
original try gun just leave your
judgment until the series ends was that
was that something that you expected
that kind of like reaction I mean I got
the same reaction as I told you earlier
when I first look at the show the
concept arts and stuff oh okay so
um based on that I I knew that I mean
it's a precious precious thing to
everything yeah so how can we make
something precious and create something
another precious thing right so it's not
to overwrite that preciousness yeah just
create something even more precious yeah
inside of it okay so
um we
um we're very closely doing uh meetings
with the the promotion the marketing
team for this program and for we
couldn't do it for Global messaging but
for whatever we had Hands-On we tried to
be very specific about what language to
use what words to use what tone to use
okay I know some a lot of things were
under a wide interpretation but we tried
to make sure limit that interpretation
as much as possible so that you wouldn't
like step on the toes of the original
yeah I was gonna ask a question actually
where you've kind of just touched on a
little bit it was
um when you did the messaging
between the global and Japanese audience
how do you normally kind of navigate the
worldwide audience versus the the
Japanese Market is that like what kind
of conscious differences or any slight
changes do you do depending on the
cultures
that's really hard I never really put
into words myself I use my sensors to
really navigate yeah well obviously
you're a very unique background being
able to speak fluent English yeah
Japanese So you you're probably a bit
more in tune with both sides whereas I
imagine a lot of Japan it's kind of like
they're very much focused on Japan and
we'll worry about the rest of them
they'll get it when they get it I don't
see race
you mentioned that you would read
Twitter like is it is English Twitter or
Japanese Twitter or both both yeah is
there is there a big difference in Vibe
or response to trying first of all
Twitter culture between languages is
different yeah of course of course so I
mean depending on how fans enjoy it so
are you a cosplayer are you a fan artist
I mean just like by that people how they
enjoy is different so I really want to
be careful about how I face each group
of communities yeah yeah what do you
think is the biggest Vibe difference
between let's say the Japanese Twitter
side of the response and the Western I
mean as a culture I mean if you go to
movie theaters people don't clap at the
movies where in America where we clap at
movies I mean though there's not
directors or anything yeah yeah I
enjoyed that movie I want to clap yeah
yeah exactly but Japan they enjoyed it
but they just quietly walk out so that
kind of culture is also reflected on
Twitter so not necessarily people people
like and retweet but they won't comment
right I really want people to comment
because I see how more exact the
reaction is instead of just that liking
how did how did you like it yeah is what
really matters to me yeah I'm the
opposite I wish they would comment last
did that delete that okay be careful
go back go back [__] around and find out
yeah because like I guess that that is a
another thing I noticed as well was that
like a very common like Cinema trait
with in Japan as opposed to the West is
that in Japan they stay until the end of
the credits oh my God yeah I'm always
there awkward guy he's like all right
I'm leaving I'm not saying for this but
I guess that's like that also shows that
like I guess like in in general maybe
this is a stereotype I don't know but
like I guess like the Japanese audience
cares about like the the people that
like went into like working behind and
they're like oh okay I love this show so
much I want to know who was responsible
for it all whereas maybe in the west of
course there are people who are
interested in that but maybe not it's
not the general consensus perhaps
there's a higher intensity I think from
what I've seen good evening good good
good job right right when they love
something they love saying and when they
aren't happy about it they especially in
the anonymous
yeah because do you do a lot of like
Japanese events at all in like terms of
promotions because I know you go to like
a lot of American conventions you're at
ax last year right yeah do you do the
same kind of like promotion on the
Japanese side of things as well uh yes
I'm responsible for all that for orange
side okay so we work with a production
committee side to get that done I've
always wondered when when anime should
do is go to like an anime convention is
it purely just for promotion like what
what are they normally kind of like what
is the point of strip clubs and strip
clubs
research actually thank you very much is
it like someone's curious is your voice
actor so you go to it you know you can
sign something you can make some money
but like I assume for Studios it's
there's got to be something else because
like you know you're pretty conventions
aren't that profitable I imagine so for
my my my objective is actually uh
inspiration oh okay because um so for
meeting their fans there's not I mean
Japan there's not too many events that
you can meet fans that's true right so I
mean if you're a directory you might be
if your character is not you might be if
you're animator you don't mind not meet
your fans right so I want people to more
meet their fans and who are they so
where do they come from where are they
going is the question I always ask too
yeah so are you from this area are you
from other area are you did you travel
here right those kind of things really
matter too then also the culture so by
going to that location I mean feel that
culture yeah I mean that really matters
we're anime is a global medium so it
really matters that you get inspired by
so many things do you feel like there's
been more of uh Spotlight put on like
the international audience in the time
you've been working in the anime
industry yeah a lot I mean the business
has heavily skewed through the
international oh really so
I wish more Stu more companies will
focus a lot more on the on the global
um strategy do you do you feel like
that's only going to grow
like the the focus on the international
side I feel like it has to well because
I remember you did an interview
slow for what yeah and the guy was like
I don't even know we had an
international audience I think he was
also jokes oh was he really yeah he was
like he was like I don't know yeah in a
rare display of Japanese facilities he
was actually just being facetious I've
never heard Japanese man be sarcasm it
was funny because
no it was funny you say that because so
many people in the comments of that
video said the same thing they thought
he was being 100 serious but no he was
just joking yeah like I think they have
I think they're fully aware that yes a
big majority of their like audience is
international and like you know they're
not going to necessarily like pertain to
that audience a hundred percent
obviously right because you know
domestic is the first priority but like
I think at this point with how much
anime has grown I I think it's pretty
hard to avoid well yeah there's always
that that good that um conversation that
goes on online about how people are like
no they they only make anime for for
Japan they don't they don't care about
other countries and and when they're
making it but I suppose if it's heavily
skewed for a international market that I
I mean that argument doesn't really hold
any water yeah I think I think there's
still like I don't know you can confirm
with this but like I guess like they
still they do care about the
international audience but I guess it's
not like first priority for a lot of
Studios right um I mean I think it's
more of that a lot of the workforce
won't understand but of course yeah I
mean they could say they're in San Diego
look at marketing data and say oh we
understand it but they don't understand
because they're never from there right
yeah in America
decades on both sides I got the feel but
everyone just just maybe have a tour
into America for California yeah yeah so
I guess that's like a reason why you
send these uh like stuff to like be more
experience more inspiring never thought
about it yeah I'm trying to get away
from I feel like I'm in America all the
time yeah I need to stop listening to
America but I guess yeah from a Japanese
perspective right you wouldn't
inherently get a lot of experience with
foreign countries and and I suppose
getting more in tune with the global
world is
they always like other Japanese staff
members always shocked or surprised when
they see like the international fan
reaction when they go to a convention
like Anime Expo or you just went to
sakura con as well right so we just
started sending people to because Kobe
we couldn't do it yeah and I joined five
years ago so I want that's the goal I
want to do but now that we have Trigon
Stampede we're doing the tour so I mean
director and my other partner producer
was able to experience so next month I'm
taking my animators to another con right
so I want to keep on doing this to make
sure that our team are more rich in
experience okay yeah that's such a cool
way of looking at it yeah very cool just
get back to animating what are you doing
I mean
it's like all right we've taken you to
this trip Club back to animating come on
you're telling me the secret to Studio
animators in like the dingiest grossest
strip club in like Ohio okay so in
Vancouver my director wanted to go to
this street that's very looks I'm like I
can't not walk in that street
I look like a tourist
I'm a jacket by my side that fast my
both my hands are tied up I can't walk
in that street
okay give me a moment I put my back Pond
zip it up zip it up yeah and like put my
hands on I'm like okay
I was ready
so like so you're saying the secret to
Studio orange is your staff members
touch grass that is
holy [__] going outside is the secret
this entire time
God damn basement dwellers who are like
hoping to join the anime Community
you're like no no like this
where'd you take your staff members if
you want to show them your like American
Ninja
where'd you take them where'd you take
them I mean every city is different so I
mean right I would love to take every
single city
um what's your favorite City my favorite
City well I mean I grew up in L.A so I I
was seeing Oliver until I went to
Seattle Seattle
do you want them to have like a
quintessential American Experience you
like let's go to the gun range let's go
to Denny's a real Denny's let's go to
IHOP let's just have like this let's
just go full American oh my God that is
the culture shock experience for them
they should do it
you just like see the calories
I mean if it creates culture shock they
should go to yoshinoa in America oh it's
totally different
is not that much of a culture shot so go
somewhere else
it was a culture shock to my system I
think my body fought back because I had
the McDonald's in America I was like
this can't be it wow how I just love to
imagine Japanese people going to
McDonald's in the US being like wait
it's gross the biggest culture show in
terms of like uh when I came to Japan
was that the KFC didn't have gravy I was
like that's that just doesn't seem right
yeah it feels like a fundamental mess up
and the court side is not sweet yeah
yeah yeah it's like lettuce and carrots
doesn't have gravy I feel like that's
like that's everything that's like
McDonald's
you know what I mean it's like what with
us the courts are you know me
I I agree I agree with everything I
agree I agree which is rare for me it's
very rare what is someone like the
biggest culture shocks that your staff
members have gone through I mean go into
that shady place was one thing last
weekend oh that was last weekend
I mean they just come back
I think that a lot of Japanese people I
spoke to when they've been to California
is like the homelessness they're always
like oh my God like this is insane the
Vancouver's part was really more than
that I think it was pretty bad too hey
there was a guy butt naked right there
I mean yesterday he was a bit Monday kid
too oh God no I think when I was there
it was too cold to do that
extremities would have been frozen off
if you did that I reckon those those
cheeks it's the same guy it's the same
it's the same butt naked guy every day
so when you since since you're from La
where do you normally take where'd you
normally take people to show them to
show the Mellow
skid row no it's got to be right I mean
when I used to
um staff at MX for my radio turned on
once and like the one volunteer was
Japanese he wasn't from local right like
I'm in a place called uh Compton
[Music]
it's unfortunate that I think now uh in
L.A like Skid Row is right next to Tokyo
Little Tokyo oh and so yeah a lot of the
time during the convention people end up
around that part it's like no don't
don't go there yeah but right away and
don't walk around too much and it's nice
to the Art District as well yeah yeah
sandwich between
I mean naito loves American toys so we
went to uh frankincense uh there's a
place called frankincense where all
these um toy sellers Gather in this in
the storage garage like a small con
right there like like a flea market type
yeah oh okay I wanna I wanna see Storage
Wars Storage Wars Japan version now
that's on my mind I just thought about
that
I mean they weren't hopping because no
one owns a storage unit yeah dude
there's loads of storage units in Japan
but I don't think they auction them off
there when they're no no no
yeah well they just demolish everything
when they don't pay the bills or
something yes
Repo Man comes in takes everything yeah
so uh what's like the F what's like the
final goal of CD orange what what what
is like what are you guys working
towards in terms of your studio world
domination oh hell yeah
like to hear
yeah and how a lot of the animators you
know initially wanted to get into gaming
is there a potentially see Studio Orange
game or something along those lines I
mean for struggling I definitely want to
do some kind of game and yeah
so we'll see what comes through that'd
be so sick what about video game
adaptations
um that's definitely something I mean
one of the projects that we always talk
about too oh hell yeah is there like one
video game you really want to see being
turned into an anime regardless of if
it's like done by orange or not yeah
that you think would be like unless
you're working on it unless you're
working on it now
on the roll
it could be like a personal pick as well
but it's been so long since I played a
lot of video games I always say I want I
want Doom to be tuned into an anime
somehow no no no I don't want to work on
dude
yeah because you know that Doom is great
as it is I wanna I want it to be crazy
I think like uh I think like a dark
souls could work I mean it's already
inspired from the likes of Berserk
anyway right so it already has that kind
of it it passes the vibe check of
potential anime yeah I mean when I
always think about adapting anime what
kind of new values can I bring to that
Community right right so like um my
recent game I was already gone into
Elder ring oh I spent 300 hours in that
world just mesmerized by every single
I'm jumping against the walls these guys
still haven't played it yet you should
yeah I know
you're only the 5 000th person who's
told us that everyone album ring is
amazing because I'm just not prepared to
give up two weeks of my life as one
month
has allowed you to have the experience
of like hearing operatic music with a
giant sword slamming down on some
monster and seeing it Buckle that's so
cool everything's so cool do you think a
Guilty Gear would be a good anime even
though that's already kind of like anime
S I mean they make their own anime too
so yeah I mean I mean those are things I
never imagined really right so so you
think that because it's so close to
anime already that there's no let's say
value in getting like a an anime
adaptation I mean it's it's more my own
imagination so yeah if I can imagine
there's a new value to that so I just
don't have that piece to consider so if
their team is like oh this will be
amazing combination I'm like oh I mean
like I could be amazed by that so yeah
I'm curious did you want did you watch
alkane yes what what did you think of
that as an industry you know an industry
veteran that works in 3D animation
because watching arcade that that blew
my mind away in terms of what they were
doing with their organization like like
do you think
do you think Studio orange is or could
get to that level so I um as of the
creativeness of our CEO right we can I
believe right but we are not ready to um
that could be money or system or the
amount of people we have yeah we are not
ready but one day I'm going to get to
that magnitude oh this is definitely not
something I swore when it when I saw
Arcane because it's such amazing it's so
good such a catchy song too
it's in my head all the time get out
and season two I think got announced
recently yeah
in some in terms of like animation
outside of Japanese anime is there any
other shows or movies like Arcane uh
that you guys get inspired by because
I'm curious because you know aside from
aside from Arcane there was like into
the spider-verse recently which was very
very impressive and then there's the
upcoming Scott Pilgrim anime right yeah
yeah and uh Puss in Boots too which I've
heard she was so good which I've heard
was incredible do you guys ever draw
reference from like American animation
at all um as a studio level we're not
really um individual level definitely
Everyone's Watching so many things right
um like for example our CEO wants to if
even possible he wants to do Tom and
Jerry one day so that's something
completely different style from what we
do right now right but we see that if he
used to do it we were able to do
something amazing right right because
like because I I think like one thing is
like technology is always evolving as
we've uh as we've already discussed I
was wondering how much you guys put
focus in just the general technology of
like what other studios are using and
doing in terms of just the animation uh
animation process in general
or is it all kind of like in-house kind
of thing
is I mean a lot of the technology we
development is in-house whenever the
technology is available on the market we
try to test it and see how we can
Implement as our own right right
um but in a sense um a lot of the
management is done outside of Japan so
that's why we've heard a lot to the
other studios in Japan right okay okay
do you guys ever think you're gonna do a
Mecca I want to see Steve orange tackle
I mean we came from America so and our
animators love Mecca
so look forward to it is there a single
animator that doesn't like makeup yeah I
feel like I feel like that's the
Baseline criteria to be an animator it's
like do you like giant robots fighting
you can be an animator yeah because you
guys haven't so go ahead yeah we haven't
had I mean Gundams going on right now
the other Mecca has been absent for a
while so it's amazing to have that I
mean I feel like gundam's always Gundam
has always been like the strong IP that
will go through the end of anime yeah
it's kind of like the Evergreen Mecca
right yeah it's just like no matter what
period there's always going to be a fan
base forward yeah yeah exactly no I
would love to see Studio orange Taco
hopefully hopefully in the future
because
well I guess uh do you have any final
words from Studio orange that you'd like
to let the audience know or get them
excited for okay
um I mean definitely try again Stampede
we're working on the Final Phase now um
what that entails will be revealed as we
move on to more comfortable time to
announce right and right now we're
working on idolish 7 which Idol anime
but this actually even if you don't
watch Idol anime it's gonna be something
amazing okay so I do not watching
if it's made by orange I am awake or you
guys do something new every time I don't
think you've tackled the same type of
show no like yeah
but uh yeah thank you very much for
coming on thank you very much for having
me a lot more uh perspective yeah more
importantly on anime and how it's made
yeah you guys were my first podcasts
[Applause]
hell yeah is there anything you want to
shout out you have a social media yeah
social media any orange Twitter yeah I
mean Orange has orange or myself have a
Twitter account um orange is CG
underscore
[Music]
we'll leave
it we'll leave it
but yeah for myself I'm it's crazy Nabi
so crazy oh yeah hell yeah yeah
hey look at all these patrons though
these are all the people who support the
show yeah hopefully they're orange
supporters as well and uh who's your
favorite Patron which one point
somewhere else yeah they're on the
screen right now oh really yeah yeah
look you see all this guy oh hell yeah
lucky you
and hey if you'd like to support the
show then go over to our patreon
patreon.com trashcase also follow us on
Twitter send us some memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on Spotify and that was
something thank you once again first so
much thank you very much yeah thanks
guys for watching and we'll see you next
week
[Music]